le cinéma maintenant avec la sortie
mercredi prochain du dernier film
d'agnès varda les plages d'agnès elle
revisite sa vie un film tendre et
touchant que nous dévoile isabelle
bechler et et stéphane guillemot je joue
nouveau d'une petite vient rouillard des
bavards qui raconte sa vie de plage en
plage la cinéaste fantasque et sur
réaliste nous prend par la main quand on
a une plage dans la tête on n'est pas
complètement foutue déjà plage burlesque
plage de souvenirs plage
cinématographique plages musicales à
niasse et collectionne est partout elle
se nourrit de l'énergie des embruns pour
nous donner de la poésie dans meynier
voir j'ai rencontré les autres des
autres et des plages et toutes sortes
déjà c'est un petit bilan de mes 80 ça
j'ai inscrit ce que j'ai déjà pu retenir
dans cinq ans j'écoute à fait perdu la
mémoire et je pourrais même pas le faire
il ya cette énergie de d'aller avec la
vie comme elle et du canal royal du port
de sète où elle a passé son enfance
pendant la guerre à paris où elle a
étudié photo et cinéma agnès v remonte
au vent on disait monte à paris
comme si la france était verticale
cléo de 5 à 7 sans toit ni loi les
glaneurs ces trois films majeurs mais
aussi des fours dont agnès l'artiste
plasticienne a utilisé les copies pour
construire une installation à la
fondation cartier agnès l'infatigable
est ce que j'ai vraiment l'air de mourir
tout de suite là
agnès varda a l'intention de jouir
d'autres plages et de les partager avec
nous aussi longtemps que possible